bangladesh now where at least seven
people have been killed and thousands
left homeless after a major fire at a
rohingya refugee camp
it tore through balucali camp in cox's
bazar and raised hundreds of tents
leaving thousands of people without
shelter
health centers and other facilities have
also been destroyed
let's get an update from our
correspondent tanvir chadri who's in
dhaka so tanvir a really sad situation
for these rohingya refugees do we know
any more about how this fire started
and what's happening to to the people
who've been left homeless
well let me just bring you some update i
mean there was a second wave of fire
actually last night around 11 p.m and it
took the fire
service and volunteers to put that fire
out till one am
in the morning today an absolute
devastating situation
save the children in a statement
yesterday said that nearly 80
000 people could be adversely affected
a lot of the learning center or rather
informal schools
clinics and health centers were
destroyed this is probably one of the
worst tragedy that took place
in one of the the largest refugee camp
now a lot of these people took shelter
among
the family members and friends because
there is no
particular shelter to actually
rehabilitate any of this
people during any tragic incident like
this so
right now on voluntary business people
are taking in
those who are left homeless now majority
of the
population among the refugees and those
camps are children
and they're traumatized by this incident
this is not the first time
in may last year there was a major fire
destroying at least 500 hearts
january this year at least nearly a
thousand hearts were destroyed in a fire
nobody still know the exact cause of the
fire but it is likely
from cooking gas cylinder these are
known as lpg gas cylinder
which are highly combustible uh each
families are given one
so it's possibly from one of those and
the flimsy huts easily catches fire
there are more reports coming in people
are still missing
we'll have to see if the number of that
increases as time goes by
thank you for the update tanvir
chaudhary live in dhaka